la jolla california i'll be at the la
jolla comedy store august 5th through
the 7th philadelphia pennsylvania i'll
be there august 18th through the 20th
austin texas i will be there september
2nd through the third get your tickets
for those shows and all shows on my
website at ryanzigler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social medias and i want to thank you
for all your support man this uh show
has really become something i never even
knew it could and i can't thank you
enough so if you're watching on youtube
please subscribe and uh leave a comment
out there y'all really helps out the
show and if you got to have more check
out the patreon it's called the honeydew
with y'all and i'm highlighting the
lowlights with y'all and y'all got some
of the wildest most [ __ ] up stories
i've ever heard in my [ __ ] life and
you can hear them too for five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free you're getting the
honey do a day early ad free at no
additional cost
and uh if you or someone you know has
that story has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we can do an episode together
all right the night pants nation tour
continues to roll on thank you for your
support in that as well i will be in la
jolla uh august 5th through the 7th i'll
be in philadelphia august 18th through
the 20th and i will be in austin texas
labor day weekend y'all september 2nd
and the third
now that's the business you guys know we
do over here we're highlighting the low
lights i always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and i am
very excited to have this guest back on
the honeydew ladies and gentlemen please
welcome the main mommy christina p y'all
welcome back to the honeybees
now you extra long hold on
do you know what i always sing in my
head now what is that it's one of those
things that gets stuck in rent space is
uh when you said to me
your mom's a borderline right now
yeah well we've known each other for
what like 20 20 years we grew up
together essentially and
i was just saying before we started
rolling i mean how much sillier
do you think you've allowed yourself to
get as an adult like yes the
responsibilities are overwhelming
but i feel like i'm also like so silly
now all right i have the perfect answer
because it happened on the way here
before i answer that plug your plug your
data stop please plug it in okay i'm
plugging myself uh washington dc at the
dc improv july 15th and 16th and then i
do cobbs july 29th and 30th seattle is
already sold out and then cleveland ohio
and august many apple tits in august as
well
brooklyn one night only september 7th
detroit chicago nashville yeah new york
it goes on and on christinapponline.com
for tickets thank you uh the christina p
on instagram
so on the ride here yes um i have my
daughter bringing my daughter to work
that she doesn't have her camp to uh
this week so bringing her here with the
dog oh and um
i have a banana for her in the car and i
go here she's like do we on we unpeel
this i go no
peel the damn banana
and then she squeezes it and it opens up
i go there you go you just started it
now peeled she's like i can't get it i'm
like are you seriously weaker than a
banana and then i just rolled all the
windows down and just started screaming
to strangers like is your child weaker
than a banana my daughter's weaker than
a banana and she was like dad
dad i can't even open a banana back here
and just i don't die and laugh and i'm
like that mom do that she goes no no do
any parents do that no
and she dies laughs and she's like don't
do that and i'm like you'll miss it i go
one day you'll miss it i said i'll never
forget your grandfather said to me the
same [ __ ] one day i'm not gonna be here
and you're gonna miss it and you're
gonna do it to your kids and she's like
no i won't i that's what i said too my
dad used to do [ __ ] too like um
i'll never forget matter of fact it's
crazy we went to this concert run dmc
with your dad yep
i know i told my friend shannon this was
87 it was together forever tour at the
capitol center um home of heavy metal
parking lot and um
it was beastie boys first run dmc second
and i just remember my friend uh shannon
my dad took us and i and his dad came as
well and i was like you know what he's
got a daughter too i'm like we just got
to remember to be that cool sometime you
know what i mean like yeah they didn't
know even know what the [ __ ] rap was
yeah you know what i mean but they took
us and the whole time we're there i'm
14.
there's this row of like just
18 19 year old college girls right here
and my dad's just going hey girls this
is my son ryan i'm like shut the [ __ ]
dad he's like it's ryan right here
what's up y'all you guys think he's cute
and they're dying lamb and i'm like dad
shut up dad try to enjoy this coffee you
dick
did you score with them did you talk
about that yeah yeah yeah i put my hood
up humiliated like trying to
but that's the fun stuff because like my
dad too had a really silly sense of
humor he um he would buy those funny
glasses with like the groucho marx stuff
or like swirlies and he always had nice
cars so he would get um he had a jaguar
so people would normally look at the car
because it was like a special one and
then he'd be like put the glasses on oh
yeah yeah so like people would look at
us and see and that kind of stuff was
fun or like a noisemaker that made the
sound of a cow like
or whatever and we'd walk through like
department stores with them and that
stuff is the best
and i taught my kids to meow lyrics uh
two days ago yeah when like if you don't
need to know the words to the beastie
boys you can just like meow and they
thought that was the silliest thing and
that i don't know that's the fun [ __ ]
right that's the stuff that matters as a
parent those are the s that's the stuff
that sticks those are the memories that
stick it's not the
i'm trying to tell my daughter it's like
she's got [ __ ] like we're doing great
jobs as parents all right my my daughter
has
six necklaces you know what i mean like
all this [ __ ] like jesus christ
and i told her i go you know i got her
something like little ring or something
i said listen don't become so attached
to these yeah i want you to tell you now
because i know i was like the thing my
dad gave me and he's dead like man get
[ __ ] that like remember the memories
it's not about this ring it's true if it
ever falls in the ocean [ __ ] it it fell
in the [ __ ] ocean you know you
laugh about it like oh there it goes but
i think you and i were so attached to
material goods as a kid because it was
like
when when's the next one going to come
like my kids yeah we might not get we
might not get another one of these hold
on tight to this
the other day my kids were like had dog
bites out of it it's still wobbling in
the air like we don't know we're good
enough or god forbid you're slinky
remember
i mean the purpose of the slinky is to
buy another slinky because those metal
[ __ ] get twisted within seconds
yeah you keep the could play that is
done so i remember my parents being like
oh we're not gonna buy this nose no more
slinky this is the end of slinky and
just like what
so i tried to preserve the slingshot
yeah and then they made plastic ones
after that
some [ __ ]
amazon shits here in two days if you
wanted a slinky you had to go drive to
the [ __ ] store to get the
slinky
yes and most parents just didn't want to
get up and go do that that's why i told
my kids they go well why didn't your
daddy buy you another slinky and i said
well back then you had to actually
do something together get the
[ __ ] slinky the slinky store
and who the [ __ ] wants to call the
[ __ ] slinky store
so yeah telling them stories about so
you grew up here in the valley and
you're back right now in the summer and
you said you've sort of been
going down memory lane a little bit and
and i asked you if it was an intentional
thing or if it's sort of like this
this calling or is it happening uh are
you taking the kids are you doing some
solo like what's going on yeah so okay
so we brought the kids out here just
because the texas heat is like super
unbearable you know so we're looking for
places to get out for the summer and i'm
like let's just go and stay in la like
you know on the west side it's dope it's
beautiful
so um
yeah so now i'm revisiting these
neighborhoods that are like
you know they're the same but they're
not it's like like when i drive through
places in austin i don't have
attachment to any of these locations so
i'm free emotionally like i'm pretty on
whatever skates but because like every
block in la has a different memory for
me because i grew up here so like the
other day for instance i went to the
liquor store
that my dad took me to like every
freaking day
of my like 9 through 11 years of life
and was actually the first place i found
mad magazine and cracked mag so i'm
really grateful to this yeah it started
my sense of humor and i agree oh it's
dope
and we talked about darby um
[Laughter]
i know exactly those toys you're talking
about like
[Laughter]
shitty [ __ ] not toy like off brand
barbies like
why couldn't they just have like
the real barbie i mean would mattel not
want their [ __ ] to be said you get that
[ __ ] at the checkout at ralph's yeah you
know there's oh yeah
so anyway
i got to go back to the liquor store
that my dad would take me to and buy
liquor and i've never done that before
in that store you were always just a tag
along huh yeah this is your first adult
purchase in that store yeah and i was
buying like hard liquor for like uh you
know tom and i had like some tequila for
the whole summer like not just for today
just for the whole summer
it was very surreal
and like
it was closing a loop
in some way like i'm back here but i'm
not the same i'm not a kid anymore i'm
this adult with agency but it still
feels like i'm a little kid it's like
i don't know i'm closing all these
emotional loops being home
i think
especially with my pop around my dad
because this this was his turf where i'm
staying in la was like where he where we
spent a lot of time together have you
gone to that bar where he used to dance
with sailors it doesn't exist anymore
what's there now the beef and barrel it
was called the beef and barrel
that doesn't even sound enticing
and it was next to the velvet turtle do
you remember the velvet turtle
well maybe that was just an la thing it
was like a high falutin chain restaurant
oh really the velvet turtle was where
you took a [ __ ] that you really liked
oh yeah it was like a prom date
okay all right velvet turtle i mean it
was fancy
yeah the beef and barrel we used to go
every friday sometimes on a school night
too going to school like can you imagine
me taking my daughter out right now i
couldn't imagine kicking it at the bar
with my kid right now on a school night
we're just taking her to a bar just
taking her apart just sit here and play
on your tablet yeah
but i didn't plan a tablet i was just
like dancing and and meeting people and
like running around did your dad take
you to bargain your mom my dad wasn't a
drinker like that at all my dad was
always working you know yeah he had to
support you and honestly too like there
would be if there was a beer in the
fridge it'd be there for a while i'm the
same way i've had i've had
coors light in my fridge for i'll drink
them here and there you know what i mean
i'm just not a huge drinker yeah but it
would be in the fridge forever well
that's good yeah my dad used to have
these beers i don't know if you ever saw
them where
if okay when the bottle was cold it was
a picture of a girl and then when you
drank the bottle you got to see your
titties
i don't know is that saint paulie's girl
i i don't know which one that is
where did you even find it he's like i
made my own labels
he's in there for hours
i made these babies when it's cold
like could you imagine that's his life's
work like i gotta put the titties on the
label
oh yeah stuff you see way too early way
too early and like
that's another part like i'm having like
flashbacks to that stuff because you
just you know you go on with your life
you don't think about it or like you
know the rubik's cube in our house that
had naked chicks on every side and
you're just like oh yeah
i don't think he had much um
sympathy to the fact that i was a little
girl
you said that to me before and i do
agree with you but also even if you're a
little boy that's a lot
that's a lot early on you know
but especially a girl it's a lot it's so
over stimulating
way you do not need like you don't need
to be
meticulously looking at dicks and balls
and trying to line them up
properly you know i mean like oh that's
that's not the right color yeah yeah
yeah and also like there was a lot of
playboy magazine laying around and just
playing around just just like like i
would take a dump and look through
playboy
when i was like
nine or ten
and like i thought it was fun to find
the bunny because one of his girlfriends
were like oh you don't know there's a
hidden bunny and i've covered everyone
yeah like [ __ ] highlights magazine
remember like [ __ ] sit down over here
do you know that's one of those things i
said in my head wrong for years what
goofus and gallant i would say
yeah you only said that in your head not
out loud the first time in my life i've
said it out loud right now right here
this is a honeydew experience how do you
know that was wrong i don't know because
you just said gallant
wait you're telling me all these years
of your life you've never said it out
i've never said it out loud what if i'm
wrong
[Laughter]
but i feel like
this is cool
maybe he's french
they never spoke we don't know oh
yeah goofy son gallant gallant cause
isn't the word gallant how was the word
gallant spelled i think gallant is
g-a-l-l-a-n-t and it means like you know
the opposite of of goo
yeah yeah [ __ ] and not [ __ ] yeah
yeah douchebag
very you know well-mannered person
probably a good good person the sort of
touchier manners like goofus
goofus just you know leaves his trash
everywhere and galant
picks it up right yeah
that's exactly right
like the mitsubishi yeah like
the mitsubishi galah
so yeah so i'm like i'm having like
memories do you ever have those phases
where because i don't remember
there's huge chunks in my childhood i
don't remember and i was talking to miss
pat about it a million years ago because
i wanted to write jokes about it and she
goes you just need to start thinking
about it like just try to remember and
then it'll come back to you so a few
years ago that's what i started to do
and then i was able to write jokes about
certain memories i've had and then but
you know it's like it's like an onion
like i feel like recovering from
childhood stuff is just it's years it's
like okay well first i can learn to feel
something without being terrified of
feeling something
okay and now i gotta go like figure out
how to have the tools to deal with
everyday life okay and then okay well
now i'm gonna go back and deal with the
past trauma it's like oh god i'll learn
how to swim okay i can swim now now i
gotta learn how to swim and [ __ ] okay
let's dive into that [ __ ] right now i
gotta learn how to hold my breath and
not swallow the [ __ ] no no no no no no
no it just never ends and the [ __ ] just
keep pouring it in don't they
it is crazy it's crazy i i've done it
i've did it one time um
did what not too long ago when i went
home i did a tour of all the places i
lived
and it's a lot yeah and this was just
maryland too you know i just did
and then i came out here and did it out
here too because i've lived in a bunch
of places here too but maryland i did
all of them from the city
all the way to the county back to the
city my grandmom's like all these homes
and jesus they all look different
you know they all
look different meaning they are
different relative to each other or look
different to you now as an adult yeah
the second second one there yeah the
latter the la the later the land
the latter so so what do you mean they
like so they look different as a
grown-up now my dad when we were kids
bought two two years we had real
christmas trees so we went out to this
little farm and you dig up the roots and
the burlap bag and then you put it in
your stand then you just water and keep
it alive for a month and then after
you're done you take it out and you
plant it in the ground that
motherfucker's a pine tree well he put
two of them out there these this was a
basement
uh main floor and then two more stories
this was my favorite house before it all
went downhill and those trees are both
taller than that [ __ ] house now wow
it's been
i mean [ __ ] 40 years like it's crazy
um and then this little shitty apartment
we lived and we lived in this one
apartment christina in this place called
westminster like you have here but we
called it westfincter
why do they they always have to name
these horrible places something regal
yeah the collins manor and you're like
it's a [ __ ] guys yeah [ __ ] sucks
the region is a regency in there so like
get your [ __ ] regency out here
um but this hallway
i i misspoke but i didn't this apartment
was a hallway so when you walked in
it was just this tiny little square okay
and then another square here was this
was the living room this tiny little
square smaller in this room here i would
say this room if you split it in half
was the living room and kitchen and then
it was a hallway that just had bedrooms
cut off of it it's kind of exciting
yeah even you saying it's making me sad
like i want to cry because i know what
you're i know this this is a [ __ ] that i
grew up we don't have heat
or at least my mom's not paying for it
so you know what we have kerosene
heaters no
why do they always go cheap on heating
and cooling
eaters we're in [ __ ] sixth grade my
brother's in like third we're in charge
of pouring it into the thing
kerosene
okay on a carpet floor and a tiny ass um
one's holding it i'm guiding it in or
whatever and then you gotta pump it in
there and you fill up the base then you
[ __ ] light it and then we're boys you
know what we're doing yeah my mother's
in the back we're standing over spitting
on it watching it sizzle and [ __ ] like
gum on it and stuff
just touch it i dare you to touch it
of course and then hold their hand
and let me guess flame thrower oh i mean
kerosene heaters we had i mean how much
more dangerous was it to get you she
could have burned the whole [ __ ]
complex
and you guys rather than just pay the
heating bill yeah my dad would do the
same thing with cooling what is it with
dads in air conditioning it's like they
feel like it's it's like this crime to
pay for ac my dad got a [ __ ] swamp
cooler have i talked about them no i
don't know but i know what one is
they're massive
i see i didn't know almost i'll move to
california they're like that's a swamp
cooler i'm like a what uh-huh so it
basically i guess there's cold water and
then it blows the air from the water so
basically what happens is your carpeting
will get a nice damp layer of liquid so
you wake up at six in the morning and
you're like everything's wet
and
damp and moldy and you're like we could
just just pay for these
you're ruining the carpet you're ruining
the house from
decay
you just gave me a whole flashback of
something i forgot about
for many people getting financially
healthy means dropping the weight of
credit card debt but where do you start
when it feels like a never-ending cycle
upstart can help you pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily with a
personal loan so you can start living
your life whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand 000 you can
even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew
don't forget to use my url to let them
know i sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew for all of your summer travels
whether you're going abroad or staying
domestic and want to immerse yourself in
the culture now is the perfect time to
start babel babel is the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions thanks to babel's
easy bite-sized language lessons there's
still time to learn a new language
before you reach your destination with
babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcast games videos stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20 20-day money-back guarantee start
your new language learning journey today
with babel right now save up to 60
off your subscription when you go to
babel.com honeydew that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
honeydew for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
now let's get back to the do
we got ac after my dad made the mistake
of getting something called an attic fan
have you ever had an attic fan it sounds
just as stupid as the swamp come on
never heard of it until then and i've
never heard of it again like i'm like
who who hustled you into this thing
so my dad like when he had to when my
mom and dad split my mom wouldn't put
you know fans on or anything so we hung
a thermometer in the house and it would
get well over it get 102 105 in the
[ __ ] house okay
so
my dad's like we didn't
we had just fox fans like right here
and there was always a piece missing
i hate box fan to me is like one of us
[ __ ] got it right
it reminds me of the worst times of my
life a [ __ ] box man
god
oh god so they get this [ __ ] attic
man christina yeah what is this that's
like what is this what in this so it's a
uh one opening in the ceiling one okay
like a centrally located opening that
has slats and you flip the switch on
and there's a there's like a a fan
up there a massive power fan that's
supposed to suck out all the hot air
because hot air rises
well our [ __ ] went from like 101 to like
99. you know what i mean like that was
[ __ ] like all that money you
shouldn't have my dad gave up i was like
i'm just getting such rare
right because in theory that sounds
lovely but there it's never look there's
a reason ac is put in every [ __ ]
normal person's house
it's the first first world thing guys
you're paying the extra you're not
paying the extra money you're paying the
extra when you try to short you know
shortcut it and can i tell you that my
husband um taught me that lesson because
i think immigrant science making sure my
kids are okay
fine
there's always immigrants always
shortcut you know it's never just like
oh
tires on my car needs to be replaced
okay so go to this guy i know this guy
he's good he's not going to [ __ ] you
over he gives you this it's a used tire
but it's still right yeah it's always
something four different tires oh yeah
so like my husband's like just pay the
money get it done right like that's the
american way in my mind of doing things
so my father one time
some creature died in our attic here in
the valley and it was a summer time oh
no hot as [ __ ] august maybe a raccoon or
a possum
and we start to smell it and the there's
flies and everything and in the bathroom
you know they have like a square cut out
and then you can push it up and go in
there i go we'll call animal services or
call somebody to come get rid of this
creature he goes no no you don't need to
[ __ ] pay for that he takes a glue gun
i already like the glue gun blues
the square shot no
he didn't even go get the animal out
why would he do that yeah no and just
sealed it shut and like eventually the
smell and the flies went away but i mean
like a monster monthly yeah
i mean could you imagine no
could you even like how much could it
have cost him really to get
i don't know i don't even know who you
call but there's somebody that's gonna
control yeah you got a dead [ __ ] atom
on your house but wouldn't you i would
pay thousands of dollars to have that
thing removed a thousand dollars if
you're gonna do that call me
and you all need that that much call me
i'll come get that a rotting animal in
your house
yeah i'll kill it for you and take it
out
a rotting animal
now looking back as an adult you're like
yeah i would have paid how much maybe
300 really i think that's reasonable
yeah and back then it was probably not
even that
hundred dollars yeah there's a guy
coming out for a hundred bucks but you
probably want to eat it
sure
sure
but it's wild where you think about
these shortcuts you're like we weren't
that destitute
we weren't destitute
i tried and
no i
these days it was all you're right it
was always the shortcut back then like
how can i save a buck this fell off a
truck
you know what i mean this is gently used
you know that kind of [ __ ] you know
shortcut shortcut shortcut these days i
don't i it's i already know for me
it it is
the only way for me is it's the long
road yeah always what it is and it's
always the better way anyway i'm fine
with it i know
my lot in life
but the thing i do look for these days
is no shortcut but a loophole oh yeah
i'm looking for the loopholes you know
what i mean like
i'll take the long road but if
somebody's like hey real quick
give me a thank you yeah
i'm taking it because that's what's the
loophole yeah that's what amer like
white american whatever that's how i
picture it in my head that's what they
do
it's not you don't break the law you
find the loophole in it and that's how
these [ __ ] do everything everything
that's what i learned
yeah and and everyone has a that's what
i keep telling like all these guys like
get your money right this [ __ ] the s
corpse all exist because rich people
figured out how to [ __ ] get tax
breaks and [ __ ] we can do that too yeah
loophole yeah just do it well everybody
utilizes them when you think of even
like the orthodox uh jews you know they
have their sabbath but then they'll
um they'll rig the lights to turn on
themselves or something like that right
like everyone does it funny story you'll
appreciate this yeah
when i first moved out here one of my
early jobs i was uh
like a concierge and front desk at uh
beverly prescott it was called it's the
lowe's motel now it was at the corner of
piano and beverly will oh it was the
little road that went from wilshire to
pico but it was still beverly hills okay
and that neighborhood right there is
very orthodox jew
um so their sabbath is sundown saturday
to i mean excuse me yeah saturday to uh
no friday to saturday yeah yeah saturday
is the day
and they're not allowed to use
electricity you know i don't know any of
this i'm learning all of this being in
this neighborhood i'm just this [ __ ]
idiot from baltimore i have no idea
about orthodox anything
well
our front [ __ ] door to the hotel was
a push and then it'll electrical catch
it and carry it
does poor [ __ ] pushed that door
open and when he he went to go and went
he was like this diselectric we're like
ah yeah he was like oh he went crazy
right so i calm him down i'm like look
man that's yeah just [ __ ] up he's like
i go but do you need help and you're
because tim his wife and his two kids
i'm like do you need help with your
lights and everything's like yeah so i
go up
and
he's like just give us a minute so i go
because i think it'll like handle
something yeah
nothing so i'm only looking at the
[ __ ] light out in the hallway which
also there's electricity right on the
other side of this door
that i can see
you know what i mean
so i go up and i turn all their lights
but he makes me work my way
you know in to out i can't see [ __ ] i
trip over their [ __ ] lug listen i ate
it
[ __ ] hard i go downstairs and the
next day this [ __ ] gave me 20
tip he did he felt terrible
he felt terrible that's good at least he
tipped
but all of it is like you say it's
with a little [ __ ] wink and a nod
like yeah you don't have to but
yeah all right so what's going on with
the trip like what's happening to you as
you
it's kind of wild dude like like i said
so i've been in you know uh therapy for
like what 12 years now and it's like
you just like i said it's like process
process process and then i think i'm
like i mean i'm coming to grips with
that you're just never
100 you're never you're just always
going to struggle or not struggle but
you're always going to have
whatever it is that you're dealing with
it's always going to be there
so i'm having you know uh i think i'm
i'm having like
memories come up now that i haven't
remembered or i don't know i don't know
do you believe in
do you believe in repressed memories
like fully repressed where your brain
just yeah
yeah when i was what i was gonna say
when i went on that tour back home i
pulled up out in front of my friend's
house and he's
he's his dad's the one who was my dad to
the concert his mom was my mom growing
up his little sister was like our little
sister and she died in a car crash and
just we spent
every [ __ ] day there after 16 with no
parents like we're over there swimming
hanging out like we were their kids
and i pull up out in front of there and
they're it's long gone you know they've
moved and everything else and i [ __ ]
lost it oh i lost it i couldn't believe
like i was embarrassed like get [ __ ]
get yourself like if it went for a while
i was like shut up but it kept going
i was like man i didn't know i had this
even [ __ ] in me and i started
remembering
everything from the smells and you know
what i mean just like whoa and you're
seeing this image in this image and it
happened right there and
yeah
i believe there's more to come to like i
don't think all my memories are i don't
know if unrepressed is a word but
i think i'm someone just down there
kicking it waiting for
their calling but then i heard something
on when someone was like yeah your
memories aren't even
really real over time every time you
remember something it changes slightly
and especially with age it's like
i mean what is expectable expectable you
know what i'm saying like what what is
within rights within reason to remember
from your childhood and then what is you
fabricating what is i don't know but
then i do know that my you know your
body
reacts
you have that uh somatic memory i don't
know if you've ever had a panic attack
or were you
it's your body's reaction to something
it's so uncontrollable so i believe in
that obviously because that's tangible
but it's kind of a mind [ __ ] you know
because you're like the other day i had
a panic attack and like
i don't have them frequently i still
haven't had one in i don't know gosh
ever ages so i was like whoa what's what
was that where were you i was sleeping
and i've never had this where i out of
us dead sleep and were you having a
nightmare into it or no don't remember
oh you don't remember so that's how
maybe freaked out i was from the dream i
had had that it had traumatized me so
much or something
so that's what i was asking you since
you're in a different place now you
think that place had something to do
with that memory yeah there's something
happening there in austin no because you
don't have any attachments you sleep
peacefully down there yeah do you really
yeah i have i have recurring dreams now
i have recurring dreams that i'm
it's the same one over and over that i'm
20 years old i don't have my husband i
don't have my kids i don't have my
career and i have to figure out what to
do with my life it's it's being 20 again
and not having what i have without
having my life and panicking like being
helpless again um that's it that's the
recurring dream do you have one too
i used to and it's gone now that's good
it used to be um
and i know a lot of people have this one
but i would wake up
well in my dream i'd wake up like
oh my god i forgot that one [ __ ]
class i haven't been to that one
[ __ ] class and i gotta hustle
to class on a campus that i'm no longer
familiar with and when i get there it's
english but they're using protractors
and [ __ ] i'm like how much did i [ __ ]
miss and i have this whole panic and
then the panic also of it then turns
into having to move home
to save money oh god and i can't do
stand-up on a [ __ ] wednesday yeah you
know yeah yeah so um that finally went
away though but not long ago
yeah
yeah they come and they go for me or or
like but with stand up do you ever have
panic about stand up like i've dreamt
that i don't have any material like i
dreamt that i had no material and but i
was able to riff and i like riffed
through it i was like oh that's an
interesting that's good that means i'm
competent and one thing but
um
but yeah i'm i'm like i mean i feel like
my brain is in between worlds this week
because i'm like trying to look i'm
trying to remember the past because
obviously something is in there that's
like
hey we're ready i'm ready
and i don't know what it is
and i'm actually in my waking pretty
happy i'm pretty chill i'm very calm
here
so i'm just kind of letting it happen i
think in the past i would be more
anxious about it like i gotta fight i
gotta i gotta you know and and like
getting keyed up and then you just
realize like it's okay just chill go
through it
look that's what i learned through that
emdr therapy is none of the [ __ ] that i
am
feeling
is because of anything right now yeah
none of it it's all not fake but it's
all imagined
because of
um
what do i want to say what's the word
i'm looking for pre-programmed emotions
and feelings to all this other [ __ ]
we have and because this feels familiar
i'm going to use these old feelings
for this experience and it's not the
same [ __ ] thing at all and it's like
no no no like i got scared of flying and
i was like now i but i quietly sit next
to strangers and i say to myself
everything's fine what should i say
the plane's going exactly as fast as
it's supposed to be going there's not
one [ __ ] thing you can do
but sit right the [ __ ] here and let
these people fly this [ __ ]
safely to where you're going and then
boom we go what caused so you didn't
always have a fear of what what caused
it it was stella almost being hit by a
car and it just unhinged anxiety that
had been waiting inside me forever
you know i never understood what people
meant when they were like oh i feel like
having a heart attack and all that oh
man yeah and then fear of heights came
along with that too
um i still think that's a reasonable one
like i don't need to be on top of a
[ __ ] mountain looking over the edge
you know i think if you're not scared
something's got damn wrong yeah yeah but
but i went to therapy and
i can say that em and drew recommended
it um i can say it works because i
[ __ ] sleep on planes now and i knew i
had to get it fixed because all we do is
[ __ ] fly there was no way i could do
this job without flying at some point
and i had to go get it fixed and it
worked that's interesting because i've
had um
i've had high anxiety after the birth of
my children that's part of my postpartum
fun is getting hyper vigilant and
anxious and ocd
um so anxiety comes up when you're
dealing look like you said stella almost
getting
hurt or harmed by a car yeah but it's
interesting that you'd show you didn't
choose but the unconscious went to
flying
which is central
to what you need to do to earn a living
like it was like you
do you know what i mean like
also the thing that i'm craving most in
that situation is being able to control
her safety and i'm on a plane
zero [ __ ] control
i can't walk up to a cockpit like guys
get move the [ __ ] over let me just fly
this goddamn thing and i wanted to rest
but let me take it right
so it's centrally
located or or uh factored in my living
and i can't do anything but sit there
helplessly and eat some [ __ ]
peanuts and shut the [ __ ] up yeah you
know what i think to myself whenever i
start to get scared of flying it's like
most likely the pilots don't want to die
today yeah yeah i mean unless
something's wrong
nine times out of ten they don't want to
die either no one wants to die today so
i'll rely on that hopefully
wow the mind is fascinating now like
it'll create stuff it'll
i mean when i was younger i used to have
like uh like if i when i was in a bad
relationship i would have stomach
problems like i would i would start
obsessing about
oh my god i ate something and i'm gonna
get diarrhea and then i would get
diarrhea isn't that wild that the like
the mind controls oh yeah
no doubt
[ __ ] have you had that where your you
create like uh illnesses yeah
i know my
when uh when um stella's mom and i first
split
i went through like physical hell and i
all that stress and anxiety and
worry and just letting my mind run loose
about what's gonna happen and oh man it
almost [ __ ] killed me i was in out of
the hospital for six months
i clotted everywhere on both legs found
out i had a
disease
um ended up with kidney stones all this
[ __ ] back to back to back to back and i
know it was all
stress and anxiety related yeah and i
was 42 which is the same time my dad age
excuse me my dad was when he died
and i remember the [ __ ] i know i had
a clot and they were like you're fine
and i'm telling you it's like
an elephant's [ __ ] trying to squish
your chest and i laid on my bed it was a
sunday night i was crying
and i gave myself up i was like this is
it i can't i couldn't take the pain
anymore and i must have just fallen
asleep or passed out from it and i woke
up and i was like all right you're still
[ __ ] here
let's figure this [ __ ] out and then i
started my slow journey into
uh health
damn i wrote out a five-year plan for
myself of physical health of
career of all these things good for you
to make sure and i've checked them all
i'll check them buying a place is the
next that's what's up homie that's the
next one that's what's up see because
here's the thing i feel that you and i
or everybody maybe
you are not taught this in school and if
you don't have parents who are aware as
well and who can model this for you this
is what successful parents teach their
children and i'm not even saying it's
overt it's just like hey this is what
this is how [ __ ] this is how you
function is that if you don't
take charge of life life takes charge of
you
and you must be so deliberate with how
you conduct your affairs from your
health your mental the physical what am
i going to eat today how will i go about
the world what is my attitude going to
be in relation to this what am i going
after five years from now 10 years from
now i can tell you that i used to write
myself letters when i was 28 years old
and i was like all right this is it man
i got to be a winner i can't be a
[ __ ] loser like i'm gonna write
myself a letter every year and i'm gonna
open it on new year's day this is the
[ __ ] i want to have happened by then
all the things like you just you write
five things seal that letter up put it
away and then i would open it on new
year's day have i accomplished what i've
wanted and i would read every book about
what i want every book in the world
napoleon hills think and grow rich um
the magic of believing is a fantastic
book read every self-help book you can
get your hands on that resonates with
you and change your mind because
unfortunately when you grow up like we
do in the honeydew lifestyle
it's not that parents that maliciously
did anything it's that they weren't able
they didn't do this so we have to learn
this through outside sources through
people that have already learned this
stuff so read the books the books exist
for a reason yes
read everything everything watch the
videos on youtuber you know who's great
i loved wayne dyer i read a ton of that
guy i i like tony robbins in small doses
i could you know all these people talks
are a great thing pick what resonates
with you yeah go where and also like i
would read about what i was curious
about which meant that's what i needed
like i remember i had a lot of stuff
around money before i had money it was
always like rich people are evil
i don't know if i do i deserve to ask
for this and that i don't know if i
deserve and explore that look at louise
hay she uh she has a great talk about
prosperity it's on like itunes or
whatever like
i don't know look into all this [ __ ] man
because it all needs to be corrected
before you can succeed
i think
and we were laughing because these
people that say money doesn't bring
happiness yeah lies
[Music]
you've never been poor [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you something right now
if you
lived anywhere where you could get a
five dollar bill out of an atm you know
what i'm talking about money will bring
you [ __ ] happiness yeah yeah
yeah
all your bullshit's still there
but it makes life easier yeah the fact
that the the power of money the the
blessing of money
is not having to think about money
that's it period yes i don't give a [ __ ]
about stuff is great i love stuff too
the best part is to not think about it
yeah praise allah if i fall down the
[ __ ] stairs and i break my ankle i
don't have to go i don't know if i
should call the ambulance that's gonna
be you know five thousand dollars yeah
right right yeah right yeah i could get
help right now that's it yeah that's
rabbit i'm gonna crunch to the ear i
still live in an apartment you know what
i mean i still have tandem parking okay
i don't have central air i don't have
central heat okay i don't have stainless
steel appliances i don't have any of
that [ __ ] i got an old ass
apartment in los angeles but i'm happy
i'm happy as [ __ ]
but let's see if we can't get a house
next year god then you will but this is
the process you will it's on the list
but i knew where it would be on the list
so it's the last thing on the list
oh okay see but you put it last
you put it there yeah health and
everything else was
that's an order and also i went and did
the right things life insurance living
will and trust like i took money that i
didn't have
and invested it in
my daughter myself you know what i mean
like that to me is a good investment
yeah um instead of just going to [ __ ]
buy crypto and some bitcoin and [ __ ]
lately i've been listening to a lot of
ymh two bears where my mom's at and a
little bit of the honeydew and it's been
great and one reason it's been great to
listen is because i use my raycom
wireless earbuds to do it raycon's
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever with optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge
trust me i'm all over the place in them
they don't move raycons give you eight
hours of playtime and a 32-hour battery
life raycons are priced just right you
get quality audio at half the price of
other premium audio brands and it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds now
have over 50 000 5 star reviews i love
that i can use the earbud tap functions
to control volume or skip to the next
song and noise isolation is great to
block out all the sounds on the planes
while i'm traveling on the night pants
nation tour go to buy raycon dot com
slash honeydew today to get 15 percent
off your raycon order that's by
raycon.com
honeydew to score 15 percent off buy
ratecon.com
honeydew athletic greens is the health
and wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
simple with so many stressors in life
it's difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our bodies
the nutrients it needs to thrive all
right i start my day off every day with
athletic greens okay when it comes to
parenting
touring working my schedule is all over
the place a lot of times i don't get to
eat so well athletic greens is a huge
help and as the research changes so does
ag-1 while most nutritional products to
come to market never evolve athletic
greens continues to obsessively improve
ag-1 based on the latest research
producing 53 improvements over the last
decade and counting they invest in high
quality and reputable sources of each
ingredient and they go above and beyond
in third-party testing to ensure their
customers continue to receive the
highest quality and best daily
nutritional habits on the planet it's
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten-free
and contains less than one gram of added
sugar no gmos no tasty chemicals or
artificial anything while keeping it
tasting good to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you an immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew today again
simply visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew to take
control of your health and give a g one
a try now let's get back to the do
well you know what's funny i just did an
interview the other day about
my special mom jeans and he goes i heard
that you spent a crazy amount of money
on your outfit that you made netflix buy
it and then i heard that you spent a
crazy amount on the music on the
licensing and i go
yeah i don't see it as spending
money i see it as reinvesting
i i love stand-up comedy more than
anything else it's my pride and joy
and if i have the resources if if
netflix gives me x amount of money and
they're going to pay me x amount for the
special i just took it out of that money
and put it back so reinvesting in your
stuff to me that was more important than
like great here's another
you know whatever amount that is so i
can go buy another [ __ ] bracelet i
don't give a [ __ ] i'd rather make
something amazing and reinvest and
reinvest and reinvest it was bomb it was
fired up hair was good
so much i'm telling you look you are
you're a straight-up looking mob wife
trying trying bro that's the way it is
yeah i but i hear you i i've been saying
lately too if i could give any advice to
my younger self or any any younger
person [ __ ] comedian like
scared money doesn't win i i wish i
would have took some money i i had back
then that i paid a credit card with or
whatever and put that into myself
that's where i would put money first is
invest in yourself you are a commodity
you are your own business you are
everything so i agree yeah
wholeheartedly in
taking the money because it's it's you
can look at it like all right i'm not
getting a step up all right well you're
taking one back to take two forward or
four or five forward depending on how
you invest that in yourself you know
that's right short term gain versus the
long game i'm always playing the long
game it's always the long and can i tell
you so this is interesting so i remember
how i was saying that you end up
teaching this stuff to your children
unconsciously so my son ellis and i were
playing like a tetris type of game where
you line up the blocks and he's just
scoring 10 points 10 points 10 points
and i go no no watch this and i make the
blocks and i stack them so that you make
one big score and he goes oh
you want bigger score i go there you go
kid see so it's like you just want the
10 points to 10 points or you want to go
for the [ __ ] the money bro that's
going to be a longer game and it's
riskier definitely you get [ __ ] before
you even hit them and it takes longer
and yeah takes patience that's it yeah
dog
dawg
what um where else are you going to go
on this tour of christina's childhood
yeah you've been to a liquor store
you've gone by any places you lived
you know what now that you say that
i think i'm gonna do that because there
is
i think that's what i have to do next i
think that's what i wanted
and you went alone
yeah cried alone in front of them
then i'd leave
and i some of them i didn't like you
know some of my did most of them i
didn't because i was there because
everybody died you know what i mean it
wasn't necessarily the place it was the
reason i was in the place
that i didn't like does that make sense
yeah
um and i hated living with my grandmom
but i mean it when i because of this
my grandmother's house and i imagine
this is for a lot of people was this
special place that smelled a certain way
with the sauce and everything and then
when everyone died and we had to go live
with her
it lost that that sense of magic so to
speak you know what i mean it just
became i'm in here every day now and and
we're very much like your dead animal up
in the ceiling i no longer could smell
that
spaghetti sauce even though it was
sitting right on the [ __ ] stove and
everything and that smell of her place
just became
an everyday i don't smell anything
anymore you know got used to it i hated
that i got used to
uh living at my grandmom's house i hated
that the magic was gone yeah because it
was every day and it was also out of
necessity that you were there yeah it
wasn't choice yeah no
that's a different thing true oh how
heartbreaking at least well she was nice
to you oh she was even my mother who
wasn't was like you had a great grandma
i'm like thank god well how did your mom
end up so how did your mom end up so
much he's not her mom
yeah it's my dad's mom
yeah so what was your um favorite house
growing up
nun
he's gotta be one that's the least worst
on the list yeah i'll tell you what's a
good one okay that we we lived on
again across the street from another
liquor store
well this was my mom my stepdad a
townhome
off of vantora boulevard
and it was a town home
and i thought we had made it because we
lived it was an encino and i was like
the hills of the valley it sure is
and i thought well i'm in the big time
anyway it was great because i like the
location i was close to ventura
boulevard and i could buy cigarettes at
the liquor store when i was 13 if i wore
my bikini
that is i shouldn't be laughing that's
ridiculous
yes
13 looks like eight years old you know
what i mean you're in a bikini top
these big old hangers because i had big
old titties when i was 13. oh you did i
had huge tits already i dated that girl
in high school yeah she was like uh my
dad stopped playing with me in the pool
yeah
he stopped throwing me to slumber i'm
like yeah probably hurt his back
yeah so i would wear i had a pair of
gogo boots that i bought on melrose i
wore go-go boots black shiny go-go boots
a skirt and a bikini top and my
step-sister and i discovered that that's
how i could buy us cigarettes so it was
a great time my step sister and i got
into so much trouble
and we just smoked clove that's what i
was buying cloves colored cigarettes
menthol cigarettes
and just getting into trouble in the
valley and i like that house yeah that
was a because it was freedom i was a
teen and it gave me access to going to
hollywood you know i could take the bus
out of the valley and go get into
trouble so it was great
yeah how about you
my favorite house was that one i was
telling you about grandma oh no well so
this is one where my dad put the
christmas trees yeah so that was in
carroll county in eldersburg
and now that i look back at it so my
mom's mom lived with us for a little
while but now i realize because my mom
was a house mom housewife my dad's
driving an hour plus each way to um
which is now reagan but national airport
back in the day dc
and um
she ends up having an affair because she
she was bored so she gets a job at this
little convenience store and ends up
having an affair
and my mom's mom was living with us
because there was no way in hell they
were affording that nice ass house
back then
um and then it all fell apart by like
fifth grade that's when we got stuck in
the apartment with the hallway then my
parents reconnected thought they would
try to work it out that lasted like
10 seconds
and then after that my mom bounced
somewhere with our dad
like okay
so my least favorite will be the one he
died yeah i would say molly's favorite
i will say that um whenever i hear these
stories about mothers with multiple kids
and they're like
yeah she was bored and then she had an
affair like i get it raising kids is
sometimes very boring and tedious and
monotonous monotonous but
how does these [ __ ] have time to have
affairs like
how do these i don't even have time to
watch stranger things i've been dying to
watch episode
three i'm dying to get into it
i don't have the energy
uh the stanima is i stamina see i say
wrong so your mom's house and like
how do these [ __ ] even have time well
i can answer that yeah please they
didn't take care of their kids
that's the one thing
when you just abandoned your kids you
got all kinds of time to put stuff in
your [ __ ]
to put stuff in your [ __ ] guys it's
fine
time to put stuff on your [ __ ] like i
i don't have any time to put stuff in my
[ __ ] either barely anything
i barely tom and i barely have time to
put stuff in my [ __ ]
who are these women these men having
affairs like whole side families and
[ __ ] like i hear these stories like how
how how are you having a whole side
family yeah oh psy
family that's another thing
side family why would you even want
another family more responsibility it's
insanity
yeah you're right these people aren't
doing their [ __ ] jobs dude
i don't know i don't even have time for
anything like this kind of scandal but
you realize like your mom did that to
just blow up the family like she wanted
out so this is your way of and that's
why people do that [ __ ] they're acting
out they want to blow it up to get out
yeah if they didn't if they want to not
get caught they wouldn't get caught
either that's the other thing i guess i
mean but doesn't everybody get caught in
the sooner or later because they want
out they want out you know the guys and
women who are don't want out and are
doing it you don't even know they're
cheating on you
think about it think about it like that
no i don't want to think about it like
that's terrifying they're like yeah i
got this
can you hear me
i just can't i'm not i i don't know that
like my is so scary to me like to have a
family with someone and you finally
trust them and then they just like
destroy you i mean i think it's a big
part of the reason why i'm still not
married or anything i watched all that
i'm like
i think i'm good
[Laughter]
me myself and i yeah yeah
watching like man you don't want dad you
don't want me like i'm good over here i
got that because like i've seen i've
seen on both ends men just get destroyed
by divorce and women get destr it just
destroys you i think it is like it's
worse than death because that person's
still here and is rejecting you or
whatever
well most people who get divorces
um still love their kids of course yeah
most of them fight over who's going to
get them
not
you take these [ __ ]
it's a little different you know there's
there's different classification of
divorce there's the non-messy divorce
that everyone these [ __ ] people are
still vacation together that's all white
people by the way that's why people are
definitely white people [ __ ] yeah
just vacation with each other i just
remember my mom was so crazy that okay i
think what happened because she had
custody of me so i was with her during
the weekdays and my dad on the weekends
i think what happened was like she would
get annoyed with me and then frustrated
that my dad had all this freedom to go
party and whatever and then kick me out
to go live with him like here you raised
this kid for a while and then she
wouldn't talk to me for like two months
and i'd call like i'm sorry whatever i
did mom i love you and she wouldn't take
my phone calls no yeah she would like
punish me
for like one month two months and then
i'd go back and live with it was so
traumatic but like
what yeah your wires have to be so
crossed as a mother to not want
your children it's just
the drive to my children it's i mean you
see me even during this podcast i'm like
what's going on where are they i love
them i love you i gotta go
you know it's like constant i can't
so i think how sick our mothers um
were
are
yours is alive
yeah mine's dead thank god
it's so much better when they die
you're going to be so relieved
so good it's so good i don't know about
that she's going to watch this and be
like oh sorry christina sorry it's your
husband's favorite your husband's our
favorite comedian oh okay i told him
when i was on two bears with him though
that i think i might have i might have
bucked the trend and i might be his
mom's favorite now
about that how about if i'm charo's
favorite he goes i'm definitely not my
mom's favorite i was like i might have
got it i might have switched it up yeah
definitely
um all right so this i want to ask you
this before we get out of here mommy as
a mom
not just a mommy but as a mom like
do you ever find do you coddle do you
over correct do you find yourself doing
things because i know i do and i know as
a parent better than anyone that what
coddling can
do
be detrimental yeah because at any
moment all this goes away so i'm i'm
doing this thing with my daughter now
called big girl summer
and we're doing all kinds of [ __ ] we
weren't doing before ooh i like that
yeah and she likes it she's into it so
i'm trying new things you know it's all
help yourself yes clean your own plates
set the table i'm not cutting the tops
off of strawberries berries anymore you
eat that [ __ ] up to the thing throw it
away
[Music]
i'm not peeling bananas okay i'm done
it's your turn it's your turn yeah okay
this is really interesting you bring
this up yes so i've created a drawer in
the house that this is help yourself
summer again here's cups here's water
here's the plates here's the snacks go
[ __ ] your mother enough i i don't want
to get anybody any i stopped getting
some water for permission and then go
help yourself yeah i'm not getting into
any any more water no more and i think i
so i over correct emotionally i don't
know what the correct emotional response
is so i'll ask my shrink like hey this
happened should i have said this or you
know i try to learn that stuff because i
don't know all the time
but i'm actually uh i train my kids to
be like warriors too that's why i love
that these little [ __ ] snowflakes
right now these little [ __ ] that need
their [ __ ] safe spaces your trigger
warnings and your [ __ ] food allergies
well guess what i'm raising my kids to
be warriors savages and they're going to
eat your [ __ ] snowflakes i watch this
special i [ __ ]
peanuts are like the new al qaeda yeah
it's insane and you know that was
created peanut elephants
were created because we didn't give
children peanuts to build tolerances
same thing seafood allergies a lot of
people if they just would have let them
eat it they'd have been built up a
tolerance and they'd be fine because
that's life you take the poison that's
why when you say i'm going to go look at
all the childhood places do you know
that most people wouldn't do that of
course not that's terrible poison that's
the worst parts of my [ __ ] time yeah
but you must go through it to get
stronger and better and fitter and
better and you've got to sit in your own
[ __ ] for a while yeah you can't just get
up you got to [ __ ] look around smell
it all of it and then i don't ever want
to be here again and then yeah i went
and sit outside in front of that house i
haven't had the balls yeah
i daydream about this one
knocking on those doors and asking if i
could go in and i was gonna ask that
house but i don't think i'm ready for
you i also don't want to walk into a
stranger's house but yet
you know just
this is where i gave her cpr and she
died right here at the top of your steps
right now
you know what i mean like could you
imagine ruining these people's lives
this is where we made love for the first
time
yeah
we had our first child in this house
we're doing cpr on her down here
oh god
yeah wow i really don't think i'm ready
for that i could go into one i didn't
give a [ __ ] about
but here's the other crazy part is um a
guy that i went to high school with we
were friendly i didn't wasn't really
friends with him
um probably because he moved into our
house but he moved into our old house
and i believe his parents are still
there and he's reached out and said yo
my parents are still there if you ever
want to go through and that was my
favorite one that's the one that all you
know before all the ship went to
go there went to hell
go there that's the good one i should
probably go i should take stella there
yeah
i should do that
yeah i took um
yeah i i did take a tour of my um
my apartment life when i was this is a
few years ago and that was pretty cool
because that was actually nicer than i
thought it would be because i was like
this was this place was freedom for me
as a four to
you know 11 year old with my mother this
place was freedom and i could just run
through these different courtyards there
was israeli people persians [ __ ]
armenians gay people everybody teenagers
and i got to know what the world was
like in this small community and i had
very good times there actually
but uh yeah other places we'll see i
have to take tom with me i think to
visit some places because i want support
because i will fall yeah i'm i'm gonna
cry no matter what one i'm in there's no
way i won't my grandmother's and the one
my dad i think my grandmom's will be the
worst actually the one my dad died in
would be bad but the one my grandma
because that was
grandma's house like that was where all
the holidays were you know more
i would say core memories in that home
than any other home
crazy dude oh i can't imagine just
sobbing in front of these people
we're big fans of the punk
right here guys can you just take a pic
did you imagine lay down over there like
you're dying on your back on your back
did you imagine like remember when 60
minutes used to profile celebrities and
then they go back to their i mean yeah
yeah walking out front we're like um no
thanks
just don't shoot don't don't show it we
don't need to go back there do it that's
terrible i love you kristen i love you
too thank you for having me on your show
thank you for coming on and doing this i
hope the journey goes well not just the
local one but your life yeah you know
going great though i think we're on a
good path listen considering what you
and i grew up with
and what we made it into i'd say that
that's the success um i know yeah i we
won yeah we won because we won there's
there's only two ways right up or down
and it's so much easier to go down the
down's coming
at the end of all this down's gone well
down comes for everything for everybody
you may as well try um carlotta wood my
great friend who also does the voice of
the show said to me on here one time a
quote that she had learned and it's um
i'm glad i don't look like what i've
been through
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah i look way better
than the [ __ ] i mean i don't i don't
think i look great you do i'm just
saying i don't love myself like that but
i i look way better than the [ __ ] i've
been through i know that much i'll take
that any day you know when people are
like
i don't feel 46 i feel 20 i'm like nah i
feel every day at 46. i don't do you
really you still no you're still doing
all that dumb [ __ ] emotionally fair
enough but also we're much more mature
and i feel enlightened then our parents
in that generation were at this age and
also at 46 back then they looked like
they were in their 60s they dressed
you know i mean like i know i just
talked about this on where my mom said
we googled pictures of women in their
40s and like the 1960s and 70s and yeah
you look like you're half dead you're
dead that truly was middle age like done
done
we got a long way to go that's what's up
homie i love you i love you too um
promote everything again please
christina p online.com for tour tickets
check me out i'm coming i'm coming to
select cities i don't go everywhere
because i got them kids
but uh gotta check you know where my
mom's at your mom's house all that [ __ ]
i love you i love you i just did where
my mom said i don't know what's coming
out i wonder which one's going to come
first we'll see i don't know
thank you for having me on always you're
the best i love you i love you as always
ryan stickler.com on all social media
ryan sickler dot wait that's not even
right i said it wrong ryanstickler.com
ryan sickle on all social media thank
you for your support we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you